colorful language
[Music]
and laughter in the courtroom mr depp
was trying to urinate in the four year
wasn't he
no but the real issue at the heart of
the case bought by johnny depp against
ex-wife amber heard is an article she
wrote in 2018.
american civil liberties union spokesman
terence docherty said she didn't write
it alone i believe it was the drafting
of the opposite that was all done within
the communications department
were there any aclu lawyers involved in
the
reviewing of the op ad before it was
submitted to the washington post i think
there were four
doubts were also cast over heard's
pledge to donate her full seven million
dollar divorce settlement to charity and
that statement was not true uh she had
not donated the full amount of her
settlement
seven million dollars to the aclu
or the children's hospital of los
angeles correct at the time that jess
whites wrote this in july of 2020 miss
miss hurt had not donated her full
settlement to the to the aclu and i'm
not aware of what she did to the other
organization
depp's former security guard malcolm
connolly said while he'd never seen
injuries unheard he had seen them on
death
a picture of depp on his honeymoon on
the orient express was shown to the jury
showing him with a supposed black eye
he's walked into a door
or a doors walked into him as depp's
team come to the end of their evidence
heard is due to testify next week
in a case about lost reputation it's not
yet clear if either party will walk away
with their good name intact bethany
minnell sky news